Hey Jeremy.
>> Oh, hi Mark, just a second.
>> What are you doing here?
>> I'm building the libraries
my app depends on.
>> What?
>> I'm building the libraries my
app depends on.
I've got like eight Gradle projects
set up, and I've got to build them in
exactly the right order, making sure
each project's output is ready to be
consumed by the next project, then I
send them all over to this project here,
where they get built into my app.
>> Wow, impressive.
>> I know right, it's pretty spiffy.
>> Oh man, multi projects.
>> Oh no.
I know that face,
that's the face you make when Gradle can
automate something I've been working
hard to do on my own.
>> No no, keep it up.
>> Come on Mark, Gradle can
handle all this for me, right?
>> No, no, this is the way to do it.
>> Bro, don't hold out on me.
Come on, help me automate all this.
>> All right,
let's set up the multi project build.
>> Thank you.